harry has waded back into politics when
nobody wanted him to delivering a
apparently a keynote speech at the
united nations in new york to mark
nelson mandela day for reasons that
completely baffled me can't think of
anybody less qualified of the 8 billion
inhabitants of our planet to talk about
nelson mandela than harry but anyway he
decided to do that and bang on about
stuff like climate change let's take a
listen
we're living through a pandemic that
continues to ravage communities in every
corner of the globe
climate change wreaking havoc on our
planet
with the most vulnerable suffering most
of all
the few
weaponizing lies and disinformation at
the expense of the many
and from the horrific war in ukraine
to the rolling back of constitutional
rights here in the united states we are
witnessing a global assault on democracy
and freedom
we are witnessing a global assault
democracy and you have all got to take
climate change seriously even if i use
private jets like a taxi service
do you hear me all of you
do you
when did he become this miserable guy
he's so miserable
and pompous and po-faced oh i know it's
when he met megan all right let's um
a little earlier i spoke to endeavor
mandala he is nelson mandela's grandson
he didn't even know harry was making the
keynote speech to celebrate his
grandfather's legacy let alone lecturing
us all about climate change as he uses
jets
i had a uh
wonderful 15-minute meeting with your
grandfather many years ago 2003 i've
never forgotten it like most people who
met him he was an extraordinary life
force
uh one of the most
inspiring people i've ever met in my
life what was it like to be his grandson
um of course it's also uh quite amazing
and i must say it's uh
it's very humbling uh to see the
admiration the love and respect that he
carries throughout the world and
whenever people you know meet me and
other family members they're very much
touched
uh
by that we're so close to the man so
it's a great honor for me to be to be
his grandson so a lot of speculation
today about prince harry making the
speech at the u.n in new york
on mandela day and talking about
your grandfather do you think he was the
the right choice to
make a keynote speech today was getting
so much attention
well you know our families do share
relationship uh we've always been fond
of uh
harry coming over to johannesburg and so
as my grandfather over the years
so for us i mean i i believe that if
there is a platform to to to communicate
something uh maybe an initiative perhaps
or something that needs to be
implemented i think anybody should
really be able to take the platform and
be able to you know to put their money
where their mouth is or to or to lead by
example
did you know that he was making this
speech
i didn't know to be honest i only found
out uh on
i believe friday uh when i was actually
speaking to to one of your producers
i was quite surprised i must say um yeah
but like i said as long as it's
something of substance in relation to a
grandfather's values that he would like
to implement
um i don't see the problem
megan and harry had a book written about
them with their sort of tacit approval
called finding freedom
and obviously your grandfather was the
long walk to freedom
um do you see any obvious parallels
between their battles for freedom
of course not there are no parallels at
all uh appears uh because you'll see one
is obviously fighting for the dignity of
black people
against a vicious tyrant like apartheid
obviously as opposed to one finding
their own identity outside a said
institution uh obviously these are very
different things but i guess you know
how you define freedom for an individual
is is can be can be different
and maybe for them it was a real
struggle to finally make that decision
number one and to also be able to carry
out i mean just because you got that
decision it's always easier said than
done so to some extent maybe that's how
they felt uh obviously those are
definitely two worlds apart but you can
see yeah i mean to put it mildly i mean
your grandfather spent 27 years in a 6x6
prison cell it's a rather different
struggle some might argue than the
struggle that harry and megan have had
to
leave a palace and go and live in a
mansion
definitely two worlds apart they cannot
be compared on any level
for sure
but
my friend you yourself have also
compared yourself to nelson mandela
you talked about a
long walk to the freedom of speech
wasn't that you my friend well i think
that i think
the example i use and you're right to
pick me up on it but the example i used
was i think your father was a great uh
proponent of freedom of speech and i
think he would absolutely have said that
everyone as you indeed have said in this
interview everyone is entitled to their
opinion i think he felt very strongly
about that in fact he when i met him he
expressed himself in very forceful terms
about a number of issues and i think he
would have been incensed actually about
the way that society
is moving to try and suppress freedom of
speech no definitely freedom of speech
is one of the pinnacles of uh of of
freedom um of course of one's expression
and obviously one's ultimately the
determination to lead
one own nation i mean the great power of
your grandfather was that he always
practiced what he preached he never
expected people to do something he
wasn't prepared to do if he said do it i
think the problem people have with the
duke and duchess of sussex is they often
for instance on you know climate change
and carbon footprint and so on they
often practice a rather different thing
to what they're preaching
this is true this is jupiter you know
every year we have the world economic
forum and you have all these heads of
state coming in on their own private
jets talking about climate change
you know so i think it's time we hold
our leaders accountable and and really
let them put their money where their
mouth is and say if they truly believe
in climate change uh whether it be
prince harry whether it be a head of
state people need to be held accountable
at the end of the day do you think harry
should stop using private jets if he
wants to keep lecturing us about climate
change
i mean
like anybody you know who is you know
putting their foot forward about a
certain topic they have to lead by
example and that would have been
absolutely the mantra of nelson mandela
too 100
and dad but it's great to talk to you
you're a chip off the old block it's
like talking to a younger version of
your grandfather so i've really enjoyed
the conversation thank you very much
you've even got his love
no
thank you thank you very much chris it
was really great talking to you
hopefully i'll get to see in studio one
of these days i would love that next
time you're in town come in we'd love to
see you thank you very much indeed thank
you very much pierce have a lovely
evening
you